pop
[Musique]
m
la jeune agathe message suite quand on
veut voir quoi aussi
je vous attends d une bière alors
comment trouvez vous la route
ah oui ça me plaît beaucoup mais oui à
tout nous allons nous y rendre au fait
je crois que cette fois ci je ne vous ai
pas déranger pour rien c'est vraiment
une affaire superbe notre épargne toute
façon ça me change de mon bureau je suis
si content de faire une surprise
comment on va madame maïga a retrouvé un
jour parfait parfait
[Musique]
à
converser
or aisée
on va prendre une voiture et oui mais là
annonçons la mine depuis ce jour je
viens juste un oui
quand j'ai vu cette propriété j'ai dit
ça c'est une affaire pour monsieur nay
verrière à vous assure je suis tombé là
dessus mais je me suis dit c'est pour
monsieur n'avait rien n'allait plus à
espérer c'est fait on peux pas vous dire
ce que ça m'a fait quand je les ai vus
je vous ai vu dedans
vous voyez je vous ai vue de temps il
faudrait quand même que vous aviez de
prix c'est assez cher alors les affaires
vont bien
ah les affaires vont très bien il s'agit
d'ouvrir un deuxième magasin à nuremberg
où seul prêt à porter marche très fort
en ce moment tu es standing
alors à vous aviez raison ça a l'air
bien crois que je regrette pas d'être
venu
c'est bien ça beaucoup d'abus n'est ce
pas pourquoi vous aurez vu l'intérieur
avant la disposition des pièces le
mobilier
tenez voici remarque qui s'occupe de
tout ici est fait partie de la maison
bleue à lier tout le monde mais elle
trouve exactement
je suis content ça avait vraiment
content
quelle merveille
j'ai l'impression de voir mon travail
justifier mon argent utile
[Musique]
en fait mon cher m tout ce qui est à
l'intérieur du château et à moi les
meubles et tapisseries absolument
ça fait d'ailleurs partie des
dispositions dont je vous ai parlé
l'homme qui avait installé cette demeure
là mais profondément et il m'a bien fait
préciser dans le testament qu'il donnait
l'autorisation à ses héritiers de
procéder à la vente à une condition
c'est que le château le parc et les
éléments immobilier soit considéré comme
un tout indissociable peut-être arrêter
d'espérer communiqué à son nouveau
propriétaire
sa passion de sa maison tout est à moi
il suffit d'une signature à condition
que vous soyez d'accord sur le prix bien
sûr
et ben l'amant toi car tu as my en a
qu'une mais elle est drôlement belle
t'as pas vu non si juste à venir le voir
car oui oui chérie tiens regarde la
voile à merveille cette arrivée royale
non des maisons a progressé à ces
merveilleux qu'est ce qu'on appelle à
damas
peut-être pas si je sais pas toi tu vois
cette visite
[Musique]
tu vois erika m'élisant fait lé valises
sens là monsieur suite ne m'avait pas
menti en met une vraie perle
ah oui mais tu as raison faut choisir
les chambres eric à laquelle tu veux moi
j'vous est non ah bon et oussalah haut
il n'y a que le grenier ou non je
t'assure ils vont pièce à côté et on y
voit tout le parc la maison et mam le
village
ce sera mon château fort comme si
j'étais un ferme et prisonnière tu sais
bien si ça t'amuse en continu
[Musique]
comment c'est possible
ja oui rien de cassé attention tout cela
tu as mal nulle part
tu pas blessé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et puis le plancher était bizarre alors
moi j'ai tapé dessus pour voir comment
on fait dans les faits me touchait
puisse à craquer ben c'est malin ça que
tu racontes là parce qu'on aurait trouvé
13 heures non non non tu vas pas tu vas
pas y retourner nos toits non attends je
descends tu te rends compte qu'il avait
trouvé un trésor simple au trésor
surtout nous ce propos si pourtant
fléchir la balle on t'a vu mon taf et
m'a pas un regarde ce trek
mais attends ils devenus la peur au
caire montre c'est joli non
oui c'est joli ma chère tu crois que ça
vaut quelque chose car ouais ça
m'étonnerait comment veux tu que ce soit
possible
le château a été habité avant nous si
ses tableaux avaient le moindre intérêt
serait pas resté inaperçu mais justement
papa c'est pour ça qu'ils sont là
maintenant qu'on les a trouvés ils sont
à nous maintenant ce sera ma tu veux toi
si tu veux ma petite fille mais à mon
avis on les a flanqué là comme dans un
débarras antilles c'est ce qu'on va
faire et rica on va en sortir quelques
initiés les mettra dans les champs
oui c'est chouette c'est moi je veux
m'occuper c'est quand même pas mal fait
tu trouves pas c'est ce que je pense
c'est incroyable on dirait des copies
comme on retrouve chez les brocanteurs
[Musique]
qui lie jolin ah ouais c'est pas mal ça
il est très bon et bien on va les idées
parce que moi je commence à avoir faim
plus tard comment les hôtes y en a
encore alors à table parce que
entrée confient qu'ils seraient là
gardienne du trésor qu'est ce que fabre
il faudrait tout de même que tu lui
apprenne à être à l'heure à tort pouvoir
elle est toute excitée par cette
découverte
je suis sûr qu'elle était encore en
train de chercher d'autres toiles mais
tout ça c'est très gentil mais moi j'ai
rendez-vous à 4 heures avec dorff et
lord attend le temps de faire les
courses
si je pars pas trop tard oui mais voilà
tu as besoin de quoi a quand même écoute
ma chérie c'est l'heure du déjeuner
maintenant alors bien t'as pas en
vacances travail moi on pense à cet
après midi ça ira comme ça oui si je
pars pas trop tard je roulerai plus vite
attention il paraît que du verglas haut
niveau sont en fait pas pour autant eric
hana chérif lô pensée athée de voir cet
après midi va falloir les envoyer
bientôt
oui oui on dit ça et puis oui ma chérie
par boti commencé à retient qui veut
bien comme tu veux
attention alors on donne ma portée pour
la ola pour peace boat la haye où leur
attention maintenant towerbrook louis
puis là on n'est pas bon leurs attentats
approche la proche du mur approche
approche monte on a la coupe on est
presse
habiter ça nous fera des surprises et
c'est sa grappe de se garder comme ça
des découvertes
c'est beau être fatigué venez d'un petit
chat
billets pour maman et rassemble ses
jantes images à l'état vite
bonjour série comme ça le baby boom et
toi comment ça s'est passé
je te raconterai sa table à l'hérésie
bobigny il pleuvait tu te rends compte
j'aurais été aussi bien fait ici avec
vous mais tout le monde m'a posé des tas
de questions sur le château si c'était
grand le nombre de pièces où était le
village a visité fin et le tableau tu
leur as dit pour la peine enfin si alors
j'ai invité en c'est sa femme et bwin
est forcément à venir samedi attendent
les pins mais au contact et c'est que
les aime bien
tu te dire que ça me fera plaisir de la
montre et châteaux est-ce qu'ils
resteront bouche et en jetant son chic
est ce que je pourrais lendemain de
tableau de marche en mai bien sûr ma
chérie tu sais car nous avons décoré
presque toute la maison quand on sait
très bien
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bonjour les fantastiques chez saab doit
achever ma du choc surtout sur l'année
qu'est ce que tu as la voilà il ya un
point de vue merveilleuse regarde sous
la neige
[Musique]
allô bonjour les deux groupes
ces échanges ont été écoutés alors vous
allez aussi très bien il s'agit tout à
l'heure ils ont tout laissé d'abord ça
fait des progrès oui c'est tendance
ça commence dans une cigarette mais je
crois qu'on en tienne mon beau je vais
danser les portes à la fin tu sais les
ensembles pantalon parce qu'ils
accordent une très bonne idée mais dis
moi tu es tu as du stock
j'ai vérifié je peux tu étais pour le
tgv qui sont pas tout de suite et est
prête pour la saison
on peut médias serviles là si tu veux
oui d'accord mais rose et c'est vraiment
non mais ça fait un mal fou
elekta qu'est ce que tu veux ma chérie
tu m'as l'air bien excité un aller 75
points qui gagent alors comment trouvez
vous la maison très très bien c'est
vraiment une très très belle maison et
les chambres sont absolument ravissante
et ce parc
quelle merveille c'est l'idéal est pas
debout vous avez l'air songeur il toi
c'est toi là d'où vient-elle vous ne
saviez pas munich n'est ce pas c'est la
petite qui a trouvé tout c'est ma gueule
oui ça l'amusé oui je ne pourrais pas
l'affirmer mais je crois que pâques ou
sérieux ne serais pas étonné qu'il y ait
des toiles anciennes authentique
tu crois oui mais ça ne veut rien dire
ce n'est pas pour ça qu'elle n'aurait
pas l'air non je dis pas cela mais
j'aimerais bien en avoir le coeur net
j'étouffe on en a mis partout et si
c'était des vrais noms tu plaisantes
c'est impossible pour tard pourquoi pas
on l'a déjà associé à des découverts ou
quelque personne de l'agent orange n y
en a beaucoup d'autres
mais bien sûr plein et vous n'avez pas
trouvé vous savez eh bien allons les
voir si ça vous intéresse
on prendra le café après eric a montré
décevant
c'est bien
ah bon
chez les mois à venir
[Musique]
vois tu toi c'est pas mal non plus je
faisais mon thé le café parce que c'est
mais si vous avez passé la journée
oui mais c'était bien la peine de les
accrocher tout pour les décrocher
maintenant on se disait ça mais je crois
que vous avez découvert un trésor
fabuleux de ses toiles sont
d'authentiqués d'oeuvre
enfin j'en suis presque sûrement fait un
plan large a eu on à l'antenne dans
qu'un second tiens toi prêt ok ça très
bien
toptent et leslie mann
[Musique]
mais l'addition soir pourquoi ce visage
de femme en générique de l'émission
spéciale et bien tout simplement parce
qu'elle est la vedette ce soir pour nous
tous c'est en effet à un tableau que
nous consacrons aujourd'hui notre
émission mais quel tableau
et surtout quelle histoire écoutez
plutôt monsieur naïve et rieur monsieur
guy perrière vous voici aujourd'hui à la
tête d'une extraordinaire collection de
peintures
comment est ce arrivé et est d'abord
aimez vous la peinture
oui enfin comme tout le monde vous savez
mais c'est surtout erika sema fille et
quand j'ai acheté le château se fait
jamais sans une belle maison en effet
pour passer le week-end à la campagne je
suis maussade à voici d'ailleurs voilà
c'est très joli comme situation c'est de
me situer et bien et ça n'est pas moi
c'est ma fille elle elle tombée dans un
trou et puis elle nous a remonté le
tableau erika rica et le casque et a eu
peur quand tu es tombé vous avez dû est
effrayée oui j'ai eu très peur oui votre
mari était là on est arrivé en même
temps quoi quand elle a crié alors
qu'allez vous faire
je sais pas encore mais vous savez que
ces toiles représentent une fortune et
que cette fortune ne vous appartient
absolument effectivement nous avons un
terreau cyr qui apprécient n'allait pas
laisser refroidir votre vient est formel
les rouge et blanc le château appartient
à monsieur bergen bravo donc à la jeune
héritière vraiment pas ce qu'il raconte
mais ce n'est pas ce qui est bon c'est
bien la peine voilà ce qui importe ce
soir je n'ai même pas le fait inouï
couvrir d'un seul autant de chaleur
authentique des cycles passés et
pourtant vous inviter ce n'est pas
fréquent mais je sais plus quelle
manière vous le dira et il sait de quoi
il parle
c'est un expert vers mais un des plus
grands peintres de l'occident un des
plus mystérieux aussi un des plus rares
qui fermèrent nous savons à peine c'est
un hollandais qui vécut au xviie siècle
à belfast
[Musique]
il s'est marié à 21 ans est mort à 43
ans il faisait partie de la guilde et il
était un peintre connu
comment at il vécu dans cette ville qu'a
t'il fait nous n'en savons rien il ne
reste de lui que quelques peintures
encore il y en a très peu
35 exactement ce que nous savons c'est
que ces oeuvres sont parmi les plus
belles et ce n'est pas par hasard
qu'elle se trouve dans les musées ou
chez les riches collectionneurs de fèves
les rarissimes de les voir changer de
propriétaire extraordinaire il ya eu il
ya 30 ans à l'esma quelque chose il cru
retrouver quelques photos du faussaire
le génial va nous mais malgré la
controverse duras pourtant de nombreuses
années dans le mystère est épais autour
de vermeer aujourd'hui le doute n'est
pas permis
voici le 36e tableau du maître de delft
regarder encore une fois ce visage de
femme il éclipse eu tout ce soir
pourquoi un seul mot vermeer
via une heure de route de munich a été
mis en vente après la mort de son
propriétaire
carlsberg heures qui a fait fortune dans
le prêt-à-porter achète le château et
s'y installe avec sa femme lisa et leur
petite fille erika avec la curiosité de
ses 9 ans erica se perd dans le grenier
en tombant dans un trou elle découvre
une cachette renfermant une quarantaine
de peintures fiers de leur nouvelle
demeure les nouilles burger a vite leur
meilleur ami a passé le week-end l'un
d'eux s'étonne de la qualité des toiles
que la petite erika s'est amusé à placer
un peu partout dans le château oui c'est
le mihrab carmeille berg air est devenu
le possesseur d'un vermeil à l'eau ah
oui ne quittait pas c'est pour toi call
un journaliste c'est plus possible
alors oui oui bonjour monsieur oui c'est
bien moi non écoutés non j'ai posé mes
jeux poser dix fois devant ce tableau
mais non non non non non et non
écoute c'est plus possible on peut plus
vivre comme ça c'est un vrai cauchemar
erica est très fier à tisser à oui mais
moi j'en peux plus si ça continue on
veut même plus pouvoir habiter ici on
n'a pas un instant tranquillité
c'est je crois qu'il va falloir le
vendre ce vermeer comme tu veux mon
chéri il est tellement beau
ah oui je sais oui
on cherchait un monsieur lombard mène
une vie très retirer que son veuvage
accentuée on ne lui connaît que peu de
passions en dehors de son travail auquel
il consacre une énergie apparemment
inépuisable la musique on le voit chacun
des concerts organisés à nancy les
beaux-arts en général ils aiment à se
qualifier lui-même d'amateurs de belles
choses
non non j'ai beaucoup à faire
aujourd'hui
laissez moi simplement de quoi dîner et
ne m'attendais pas aller me coucher je
rentrerai sur mon twitter oh je serai là
il faut que vous mangez quelque chose de
chaud j'ai pris les journaux marquer
[Musique]
compte tenu des observations des experts
nous sommes tentés de croire qu'il
s'agit effectivement d'une oeuvre
maîtresse du pont
oui
monsieur tout le monde est là pour la
réunion
maïs blanc bonnet je vous rappelle que
vous avez monsieur bettman à 11 heures
je suis bon jour c'est trop énorme
oui
mais je ris jaune
dès sa sortie de polytechnique andré
lombard consacre sa vie au sidérurgie de
l'est
il a choisi de se fixer en lorraine ses
qualités professionnelles lui ont permis
de franchir brillamment toutes les
étapes et de se retrouver à la tête de
cette société dont il est devenu en
outre l'actionnaire majoritaire avec 67%
des parts
[Musique]
les vans ivoire avec même pour les
dossiers à nos trois qui pourraient lui
être utiles
monsieur il ya certainement des choses à
tirer de son expérience
je l'inviterai à déjeuner c'est mieux
vous avez vu ce ver maire monsieur qu'on
vient de découvrir l'allemagne
c'est fantastique mieux j'ai vu un ver
mais c'est un trésor pour le monde
entier reviendrai je veux dire quand
[Musique]
il dirait quelque chose que paris mais
vous m'avez demandé de rester ah oui oui
nous verrons ça cet après midi avec des
jeunes m
[Musique]
jean massima chef attendez vous abusez
[Applaudissements]
les 30 mn
l'actualité de la peinture le sens de
l'espace
cette présence de la matière le relief
de la couleur atteignent chez vermeer
une maîtrise unique en occident
[Musique]
toute la somme du travail du peintre
abouti ou surgissement de quelque chose
d'impalpable qui et l'éblouissante
féerie de lettres ou delà de l'apparence
le miracle de vermeer tiens c'est
impossible présence de ce qui n'est pas
le réel où nous vivons toujours
à l'extrême limite de la sensation est
dans une bouleversante fragilité
[Musique]
venu se jouer dans le regard la perle le
sourire c'est l'invisible univers des
choses
j'ai vu beckmann monsieur il m'a donné
beaucoup d'enseignements et certaines
précisions qui nous permettront
d'avancer sérieusement dans le dos hier
nous vous avez entendu les nouvelles
monsieur le vermeer il est alors
possible se séparer d'invermere
officines aussi venez entendu à la radio
il en a annoncé ce matin
il paraît que ça fait beaucoup de bruit
à minutes ils ont interviewé le
propriétaire nous votions s'augmente sur
la date de vente et déjà vos pieds oui
monsieur 11 mars ils vont faire une
exposition d'ailleurs avant avec nous et
toute la collection à bully à munich
ça devrait être formidable
oui
monsieur la réponse pour monsieur viard
vous avez chat lettre
alors chers amis
ensuite l'avis favorable donné par mon
conseil d'administration pour l'exercice
71 vous trouverez ci-joint en double
exemplaire avec notre bon à payer
friture
de l'entreprise c'était dur un
propriétaire qui vous permettra de
solder vos dépenses nommé puis vous
laisserez un blanc avant la signature
j'ai joué très quelques mois la main
voilà
un aveu voulez vous la télé c'est très
important je dois aller à munich lundi
aimable autre chose je devrais peut-être
aller à paris quelques jours monsieur
oui
le prochain conseil d'administration a
lieu le 15 c'est pourtant prévenez
urgence tous les administrateurs
exceptionnellement le conseil se réunira
le 8 présence indispensable mais
stipuler que j'ai une communication très
importante à faire pardonnez moi
monsieur mais rien de grave non mayotte
non tout va très bien au contraire
et bien messieurs vous détruire l art
des années j'ai pas si le maire est là
je peux voir utilité je vous en remercie
[Musique]
la nouvelle peut aller à l'exposition
werner à david h pique abrite 3 et la
france est à gauche et à droite
répondent directement les racheter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici en trois mots de quoi il s'agit
voici surtout en quoi j'ai besoin de
vous tout d'abord pouvez-vous
éventuellement et très vite rendre
disponible tout le monde à voir tout
votre avoir en dehors de votre compte
personnel courant ce que je dis
précisément les actions de la société
les titres immobiliers enfin mon avoir
certainement mais il aurait alors que
j'examine la question vous n'avez pas
intérêt avant tout d'un coup mais ça
vous le savez on peut-être pourrais-je
m'arranger pour obtenir un prêt
équivalent à la liquidation garanties
sur les ventes mais en les échelons pour
ne pas subir de pertes
arrangez vous comme vous voudrez c'est
votre affaire il faut que je puisse
disposer de la totalité de ce que je
possède aux environs du 10 mars
c'est très court mais ça peut s'arranger
je m'en occuperai bon
autre chose le 8
j'informerai mon conseil
d'administration de ma décision de
quitter à la même époque
mes fonctions de président directeur
général de la société je titrais
également nancy où je n'aurai plus alors
aucune attache je vous rappelle que tout
ceci est extrêmement confidentielles
peut conduire au bout des 2
mon cigare
merci
je reviens de munich on voulait dispense
voyant très jeune est posée cela nous
nous servions marguerittes pour
l'instant je ne veux aucune
communication
je vous préviendrai
vous avez entendu parler de ce ver mère
quand on a découvert en allemagne
je suis allé le voir il s'agit
effectivement d'une toile superbe un
joyau véritablement une oeuvre comme
celle là justifie une existence est
aussi bien que nominé d'élèves il faut
que je me fasse est représenté à ce
point
ah oui j'oubliais de vous dire ce
tableau est à vendre mais ils sont
propriétaires à les verts trop sensible
il ne peut pas supporter une telle
l'irruption dans sa vie
refuser le bonhomme ne disant rien vous
pouvez envoyer quelqu'un à munich
certainement c'est très facile il est
encore plus simple de donner une
délégation à quelqu'un sur place
nous sommes en relation suivie avec
plusieurs banques de bavière
je peux prendre des contacts et
organiser ce cas si je comprends bien
vous désirez vous porter acquéreur de
cette toile exactement je ne connais pas
à grand chose à la peinture
mais ça va représenter une somme très
importante
les oeuvres de vermeer sont très rares
je crois et il empêche aussi rarement
remplies
en ce qui concerne le prix je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait problème
vous pourrez tout engagé tout ce qui
m'appartient naturellement on sait je
veux obtenir cette peinture à n'importe
quel prix une oeuvre paris n'a pas de
prix d'élevage
pour moi notre représentant ne devra pas
lâcher les enchères c'est clair eh bien
monsieur lombard désire également que
cet achat soit anonyme pour que mon nom
ne soit pas mentionné il faudra mettre
dans la confidence que commissaire
priseur bien sûr et puis régler à
l'avancé
certaines formalités de douane entre
autres il faut autres représentants doit
obtenir de sucre est c'est essentiel
pour le transport la toile devrait
rapporter aussitôt par avion à paris à
l'adresse que je vous indiquerai je me
trouverai moi même pour la recevoir mais
je ne veux rien qui attire l'attention
un paquet discret les dimensions du
tableau le permettent il n'est pas grand
et surtout pas de police et pas de
douane
m vous aurez réglé tout ça avant un
possible c'est de la folie on va donner
c'est obligatoire vous vous rendez
compte aussi un long bain un tableau
d'une valeur paraît enfin d'élever ce
pourquoi pensez vous que je fais tout ça
parce que je suis devenu fou on garde
peut-être vous voyez c'est du cinéma et
je cherche à faire parler moi
ce n'est pas à la légère que je relance
1 mais sidérurgie amusé usine à tout ce
que j'ai fait ici vous ne savez pas ce
que représente cette poêle pour moi
c'est parce que c'est que vermeer ya 45
ans 25 ans
j'attends le moment venu le où je
courais à boire un verre mais a
dernièrement
allez
en
on a écrite par là
mes parents qui avaient une souce
mouvement d'éducation est en fait
beaucoup pour moi
on entend mener voir une exposition des
peintres du nord
c'est là que j'ai découvert permet
pouvez pas imaginer le choc que ça
marche
ce jour là
je me suis juré de ne pas mourir sans
avoir possédé une de ses toiles
à moins d'un miracle c'est impossible on
les connaît toutes elles sont toutes
dans des musées ou chez des
collectionneurs qui ne s'en sépare
jamais ou rarement pour le les
expositions comme celle d'anjou parle
eh bien c'était un rêve re et bien
depuis j'ai tout fait pour être en
mesure de répondre aux miracles si le
miracle venait de se produire
pourquoi elles sont travaillées
je suis pas ambitieux tempérament même
pas la lune
je préfère écouter de musique evous sur
le champ et voilà qu'aujourd'hui mon
rêve peut se réaliser
alors il faut aider
et je vais vous dire pourquoi je tiens à
temps à cette discrétion à cet anonymat
c'est parce que je ne veux pas qu'on
vienne troubler mon bonheur il a raison
au fond c'est tellement c'est invivable
tel trésor mais c'est plus pour lui il
faut changer sa vie ce en vaut la peine
intel dont ça se mérite
c'est mon plus cher désir depuis
toujours
tout le reste m'indiffère des gens je
dois aller à paris jeudi
profitez en pour prendre une huitaine de
jours de congés ça vous fera du bien et
la voiture le ciel il faut que je la
conduis je produirai moi même ça me
distraire faites ce que je vous dis
mortier
monsieur monsieur je vous avais préparé
des tos il faut pour manger quelque
chose
selon jusqu'à paris pour avaler
n'importe quoi
entre temps monsieur je manque il faudra
bien vous couvrir là bas mais enfin
messier alors voilà je viens d faudrait
d'ailleurs je reste en communication
avec moi j'aime margate à la au revoir à
bientôt
il ya un projet vous un peu
très bonne maîtrise bien les accompagner
déjà monsieur lombard ce n'est pas
possible nous avons besoin de vous les
sidérurgie de l'est c'est vous vous le
savez bien c'est moi c'était moi enfin
c'était nous et maintenant c'est vous du
coup andré il faut pas décidé à la
légère prin délai supplémentaire il faut
que nous en parlions je crois avoir été
assez claire je ne reviendrai pas sur ma
décision c'est à vous maintenant de
mener cette maison enfin vous êtes
jeunes garderont quelques temps votre
bureau ici à paris puisque vous devez
habiter désormais manquerons pas de vous
demander certains mots mais chez les
jeunes désertent pas bien su enfin je
resterai le temps que je pourrais vous
être utile mais pas davantage
et ceci à titre purement consultatif non
messieurs
la séance est levée
je suis ému
ce gars mais l'inconnue authentique
existe de nouvelles et et ça n'apportera
que l'ex 23-15 à la création
ici l'équipe de thierry mathisse ticket
officiel des naissances les conditions
mariant une collection entière retrouvé
par hasard grâce à la curiosité de
l'enfant le berner avec les souches
d'autant que les expertises
immédiatement demandé se sont montrés
catégoriques
mais il faut parler aussi des 45 yens
contre toi la patronne
je ne peux évidemment interdit pour
répondre que le plat sont très
superficielles
n'ayons pas encore vu leur mais compte
tenu des observations de mes confrères
tous les experts rendements sont tentés
de croire qu'il s'agit effectivement
d'une main
c'est confirmé lundi 15 heures
l'événement du siècle enfin la table
habituel elle n'empêche que c'est un
événement tout est en ordre
touché il faudra prévenir les hommes on
va les réveiller un peu mais j'aimerais
revoir les blancs les toits pour la
filature les consignes l'exhortait à
munich on a prévu oui et bien d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]